d'abord je veux vous dire que ça bonheur
de vous retrouver de retrouver marine
j'étais à nice l'année dernière j'étais
même peut-être un des rares à l'époque
avoir été à la fois à nice et à la baule
c'était pas c'était pas c'était pas
aussi cinq aujourd'hui en anglais je
voudrais vous dire d'abord que je veux
continuer d'être cet homme authentique
avec vous aujourd'hui vous dire partager
avec vous le fruit de ma réflexion avec
sincérité avec intégrité au risque de
déranger ce qui me pousse parfois à
voter des lois porté par la gauche
quand je pense que c'est l'intérêt de la
france et des français
ce qui me conduit à privilégier ce qui
rassemble avec nos alliés du centre et
parfois même avec la gauche réformiste
ou avec la droite conservatrice ce qui
m'éloigne des clans des écuries et des
égos autocentré des combines d'arrière
boutique des pressions et des menaces
qui fourmillent les français n'ont pas
le temps d'attendre 2010 est il y a
urgence s'investir pour sauver nos
églises pour lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire pour éradiquer d'islamisme
radical pour l'égalité des chances
y compris quand on vient de banlieue ou
des zones rurales pour la baisse des
charges et l'économie du partage pour
accueillir humainement les réfugiés tout
en protégeant notre nos compatriotes ses
alliés racines et modernité c'est
défendre nos valeurs humanistes de don
de soi de partage et de respect de
l'autre
c'est aussi défendre nos valeurs
républicaines
de liberté d'égalité et de fraternité
en épousant le monde réel ces trois mots
sont trop souvent piétiné par la
politique d'aujourd'hui sans même que
nous en ayons conscience incarnons nous
toujours la fraternité ne serait ce
qu'entre nous au sein même de notre
famille politique
sans parler du débat public si délétère
est loin des français un débat public
qui divertit au sens étymologique du
terme qui détourne de l'essentiel
un débat public qui se résume à un
combat de part et d'autre la droite
contre la gauche la gauche contre la
droite
ne soyons pas primaire brut aux
calculateurs soyons vrai lucides
courageux plutôt que band et nos muscles
ouvrons nos coeurs l'éloignement est un
exhausteur d'amour si souvent loin de la
france je laime plus que jamais cette
france
je la regarde qui se déchire au lieu de
s'unir qui doutent au lieu d'avancer
je voudrais vous faire partager mon
analyse il existe au moins trois france
aujourd'hui la france décourager la
france délaissés et la france privilégié
ces trois france ne recouvre pas les
classements habituel par catégories
sociales par classe d'âge ou par
richesse patrimoniale
la france est éclatée et la politique
non seulement ne cherche pas à la réunir
mais au contraire s'emploie à accentuer
les divisions a accentué les séparations
à maintenir les barrières pour des
raisons bassement électoralistes souvent
par aveuglement parfois la france
délaissé se trouve tout autant
dans certains quartiers de nos banlieues
que dans nos villages ruraux ou encore
aux quatre coins du monde
ces gens là ils n'intéressent pas loin
des centres de pouvoir des lieux de
décisions cette france est maintenue
plus ou moins consciemment dans la
pénombre tantôt jugée dangereuse égoïste
ou chanceuse elle ne mérite plus
l'attention des pouvoirs publics
quand elles ne suscitent pas au
contraire la défiance on la caricature
cette france délaissé avec des mots que
je n'aime pas
ghetto de cul terreux ghetto de traîtres
à la patrie ghetto de petits voyous
autant de réserves d'individus que l'on
considère mal que l'on nomme mal que les
partis politiques ne regarde qu'au gré
des élections
préférant dans l'intervalle feindre de
ne pas connaître leur existence car les
regarder car leur parler car les nommer
c'est prendre le risque de les mettre
dans la lumière
cette france abandonné se désespère vous
le voyez elle se radicalise elle
s'éloigne mais pas de son propre fait
par la faute des gouvernants et puis il
ya la france découragés c'est celle qui
forme les rangs de la classe moyenne
c'est à dire les professions des classes
et les médecins les enseignants qui
malgré de longues études se retrouve
sous payés c'est à dire des
entrepreneurs des professions libérales
des commerçants des artisans des paysans
qui sont pressurés qui étouffe sous le
poids des charges c'est-à-dire des
ouvriers des serveurs dans les
restaurants des employés des infirmières
des forces de l'ordre à qui on a retiré
l'équivalent d'un treizième mois
en supprimant la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires
c'est à dire des contribuables non
exonérés qui payent pour tous ceux qui
bénéficient des politiques sociales ou
ceux qui ont les moyens de s'affranchir
légalement de l'impôt
c'est à dire des petites retraites qui
malgré une vie de labeur ne peuvent
faire face aujourd'hui une france qui a
le sentiment de travailler pour les
autres et pas pour elle une france
dépossédé des fruits de ses efforts
et puis il ya une troisième france la
france privilégié c'est une france
diversement riches aux origines sociales
ethniques et religieuses multiples qui
bénéficient de la protection du système
il n'y a d'ailleurs aucune raison de la
montrer du doigt elle ne commet aucun
sacrilège ne choisit pas toujours sa
situation n'a aucune intention de nuire
ni à la société ni à son voisin elle
profite tout simplement de son statut
les règles protectrices qui valent pour
tous mais qui profite trop souvent à une
minorité de la générosité du système on
y trouve pêle-mêle certains cadres des
rentiers certains chômeurs pas tous des
hauts fonctionnaires des élus des
capitaines d'industrie qui use des
exonérations des protections des
avantages que leur statut tissés au fil
des décennies leur offre pourquoi un
jeune admis à l'université ou dans une
grande école at il le droit d'être
préparés à la mondialisation quand celui
qui a choisi l'apprentissage ou se
voient maintenu dans son quartier ou son
village se voit interdire le droit de
partir à la conquête du monde
c'est tout le sens de l'opération de
mentorat des jeunes pour qu'ils puissent
partir justement à la conquête du monde
que nous avons monté à l'assemblée
nationale thomas casse qui s'en souvient
nous devons réparer cette vraie
inégalité
pourquoi un retraité qui n'a pas eu le
droit de se constituer un capital
retraite car on l'a contrait à mobiliser
tour son argent pour vivre ou pour payer
la retraite le chômage ou les problèmes
de santé des autres n'at-il aujourd'hui
que le droit de se taire pourquoi un
entrepreneur
qui a pris tous les risques à augmenter
ses chances de mort brutale en raison du
stress a donné du travail à tant
d'autres de ses concitoyens en est il
réduit à vivoter trop ponctionner pour
pouvoir consommer la france a peur de
tout des terroristes de la pauvreté du
déclassement des migrants des infiltrés
de l'avenir peur de s'engager peur de la
solitude peur d'entreprendre sur la
question des migrants
j'ai apprécié que le président de ma
famille politique et d'autres
personnalités reprenne mon idée de camps
de réfugiés hors schengen mais ne
parlons pas de centres de rétention nous
sommes là pour redonner de la liberté à
des hommes et des femmes qui sont
meurtris pas pour les priver de liberté
attention les mots ont un sens soyons
généreux et efficace nommant les choses
quand frontex souligne l'augmentation de
faux papiers syrien ne cachons pas le
risque avéré d'un filtre et on doit la
vérité à nos compatriotes
j'entends ces peurs apportant des
solutions et ne nous contentons pas de
critiquer les autres à la soumission
d'une certaine gauche et à l'armure de
verre des le pen répondons par la fois
par le désir par la passion d'agir
l'honneur au nom duquel en défend les
plus faibles ont bravent les dangers
on résiste à l'injustice est une valeur
qui transcende l'honneur ce n'est pas de
bloquer à tout prix mais d'avancé autant
qu'on peut entraîner avec soin nous
sommes en 2015 les gens ne votent plus
pour untel parce qu'au nom d'une
idéologie d'une appartenance politique
socialiste républicain
écologiste communiste front national ils
bloquent systématiquement tout ce que
fait celui qui est aux manettes les gens
votent pour ceux qui travaillent pour
eux qu'ils acceptent d'aller dans le
même sens
si l'intérêt général est en cause je
veux que notre famille politique au lieu
de jouer des muscles ouvre les yeux sur
ces réalités
je veux que cette jeunesse que vous
incarnez comprennent que nous voulons
agir pour lui rendre possible
l'impossible je veux que la modernité
que vous portez devienne la courroie de
transmission entre notre famille
politique et la france d'aujourd'hui
je veux que vous refusiez d'être
utilisés instrumentalisés
mais que vous deveniez la génération
politique de l'espérance venez à l'image
de stéphane tiki à la rencontre de cette
france délaissé allons dans ces
quartiers abandonnés de notre france des
villes comme de notre france des
campagnes plutôt que de nous limiter à
garnir les rangs de réunions d'entre eux
soit comme nous savons si souvent le
faire depuis tant d'années venez à
l'image de jonas haddad à la rencontre
de cette france décourager allons vers
les petites entreprises les start up ou
les artisans qui se débattent pour créer
pour développer pour survivre venez à
l'image d' arash derambarsh au secours
des plus démunis qui crèvent de faim
quand nous gaspillons la nourriture ou
que nous taxons injustement les produits
de base
allons vers ces gens qui survivent en
marche du système
la formidable caravane de l'été la
formidable caravane de l'été je veux
rendre hommage à tous ceux qui y ont
participé
elle doit se muer en caravane permanente
qu'ils aillent au coeur de la vie de nos
compatriotes abandonné changer de nom
c'est bien mais notre responsabilité à
tous maintenant
c'est de changer nos pratiques nos
habitudes c'est le défi qui est face à
nous et je fais confiance
un marine brenier et jeffrey carr va
lignot pour s'y impliquer pleinement et
je veux dire à tous les jeunes qui sont
ici balayé la vieille politique imposant
une démocratie disruptive qui rompent
avec la langue de bois la langue de
velours ou la langue de vipère qui
rompent avec le conformisme qui crée le
débat au lieu du combat qui additionnent
au lieu de diviser qui réunissent ces
trois france qui ne demande qu'à croire
entre la crédulité et la défiance
il ya place pour l'espérance
redressez vous réveillez vous mobiliser
cette énergie positive qui est en vous
je veux vous dire aujourd'hui au touquet
lâchez vous foncez prouvons aux français
que nous pensons d'abord à eux
et vive la république française
merci
montrer ici au touquet l'élan positif
qui est un chacun de vous la france nous
regarde
c'est la responsabilité pas simplement
des élus qui vont passer à cette tribune
c'est la responsabilité de chacune et de
chacun d'entre nous et chacune et chacun
d'entre vous vive notre pays